[موسيقى]
على ستادلو سيل اكبر ملاعب مونديال قطر
ينطلق ثالث ايام مباريات كاس العالم بلقاء
المرتقب بين الارجنتين والسعوديه في
المجموعه الثالثه الصقور الخضر يفتتح
مشاركته او مشاركته السادسه في المونديال
بالاختبار الاصعب الارجنتين احد اهم
المرشحين لتحقيق لقب البطوله دافع الفوز
عند راقصه تانجو مضاعف حيث يشارك ليونيل
ميسي للمره الاخيره في بطولات كاس العالم
ويريد برفقه زملائه تحقيقا بالغائب عن
البلد اللاتيني وده كاس المكسيك عام 1986
على الجانب الاخر في العقليه السائده داخل
المعسكر السعوديه انا المنتخب لا يلعب ضد
ميسي وحده انما هي مباراه بين احد عشر
لاعبا ضد احد عشر لاعبون الارجنتين تريد
الحفاظ على السلسله الفوز المستمر لسته 36
مباراه والاخضر يتسلح بجمهوره
المزيد عن المواجهات السابقه للفريقين مع
لميس
[موسيقى]
السعوديه والارجنتين في لقاء المرتقب
بالمجموعه الثالثه من كاس العالم لكنها
ليست المواجهه الاولى التي تجمع الفريقين
حيث التقي في اربع مناسبات من قبل البدايه
في يوليو 1988 في مباراه ضمن بطوله الكاس
الذهبيه الاستراليه الوديه وانتهت وقتها
المباراه بالتعادل الايجابي بنتيجه اثنين
مقابل اثنين سافرت لقاء الثاني لم تنتظر
كثيرا حيث اقيمت مباراه اخرى تجمع
الفريقين لتحديد المركز الثالث في نفس
البطوله وحسمها المنتخب الارجنتيني بهدفين
نظيفين ال 20 من اكتوبر عام 1992 كانت
المباراه الرسميه الوحيده التي جمعت بين
الفريقين في نهائي كاس الملك فهد الذي
تحول لاحقا الى بطوله كاس القارات وكان
الفوز من نصيب الارجنتين بنتيجه ثلاثه
مقابل واحد وبعد 20 عاما من المباراه
الثالثه وتحديدا في عام 2012 استضاف استاد
الملك فهد الدولي بالرياض مباراه الوديه
بين الفريقين وانتهت بالتعادل السلبي
[موسيقى]
من الدوحه ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه
فهد الشهري فهد اهلا بك من الدوحه مباشره
كيف تبدو الاستعدادات
لثالث ايام الممتعه
صباح الخير نادين صباح الخير سهام صباح
الخير كل متابعين صباح العربيه طبعا اليوم
هو ثالث يوم في المونديال لكن هو اليوم
الاول واليوم الصعب واليوم الحقيقي
للمتابع السعودي والمتابعه ايضا
الخليجي بعد بدايه المنتخب القطري للقاء
المنتخب السعودي مع المنتخب الارجنتيني
لقاء كبير جدا لقاء منتظر لقاء صعب قوي في
اول ايام هذه التصفيات النهائيه او
اختبارات مونديال قطر حدود سيلاقي المنتخب
السعودي في الواحد يظهرا المنتخب
الارجنتيني الاستعدادات وتمت بالامس ست
ايضا الجمهور السعودي توافق بكثافه يعني
الى فجر اليوم الجمهور السعوديه توافق
يقدر العدد اللي وصل حتى الان ما بين ثلاث
عشره الاف او 14000 مشجع سعودي الاحتلال
التامه همم شاهدته الجمهور السعودي يتجه
الوسيله اللي يبعد عننا تقريبا مسافه كيلو
ونصف تقريبا لم يفتح لباب حتى الان كل
الجماهير هذا شهاده الارجنتيني اللي همم
يعتقد انه الاكثر بعد الجماهير الخليجيه
تواجد في الدوحه من خلال متابعتي مباراه
منتظره مباراه صعبه لكن ان شاء الله
الاخضر قدها هذا عودنا يعني بالذات في 94
كانت البدايه امام منتخب كبير مرشح همم
المنتخب الهولندي وفاز بصعوبه قدر نفسه
مشرف اتمنى انه نكرر نفس
الانجاز اليوم امام الارجنتين من خلال
الفيديوهات
الخبره والثقه وحتى في الجمهور الحاضر من
قبل المنتخب السعودي هل في فعاليات على
هامش المباراه مثلا في الدوحه تحدثنا عنها
تجمع للسعوديين هنا وهناك
نعم نعم المجلس الجمهور الرسمي بالاضافه
الى وزاره الرياضه راح تقيم مسيره قبل
المباراه مسيره رسميه للجمهور السعودي
بازيائه وباعلامه تنقل الحماس
اللاعب تنقل الحماس ايضا والثقه المشجع
لتشجيع فريقه طوال 90 دقيقه مسير رسميه
راح تكون بالاعلام ان شاء الله رح ننقل
لكم كل التفاصيل للجمهور في نهايه برنامج
ان شاء الله من داخل الملعب بعد فتح
الابواب ان شاء الله راح يكون دعم رسمي
امس ايضا كان في البيت السعودي زياره
مفاجاه لوزير الرياضه اسمه الامير عبد
العزيز بن تركي
شده من المشجع السعودي رفع وتيره حماس
واللي سبقت ايضا من خلال الخطوه الاولى من
لقاء الامير محمد بن سلمان بالمنتخب
السعودي اللي وجه رساله كبيره رساله عظيمه
بانه استمتعوا قدموا اللي عليكم و النتيجه
يعني في حكم القضاء والقدر لكن اليوم نشجع
السعودي جدا متحمس من يومين من بدايه
توافق بشجع سعودي وهو متحمس ان شاء الله
انه تصل الرساله للاعب الجهاز الفني
لتقديم المستوى المرضي اللي ننتظره من
الاخضر السعودي امام الكبير المنتخب
القطري يبدا ثالث ايام المونديال واللقاء
المرتب بين السعوديه والارجنتين والكل
ينتظر هذه المباراه حدثنا عن التحضيرات
داخل الملعب امم
طبعا الملعب اللي بيحضر له ميزه اخرى غير
انه يتابعني مباراه كاس العالم الملعب هذا
نهايه كاس العالم ما راح اكون شيء اسمه
استاذ لوسين راح يتحول الى الخدمه
المجتمعيه مطاعم مراكز حكوميه مازارات
متاح فهذا فرصه كبيره اللي يحضر انت حاضر
السعوديه والارجنتين او لقاء اخر طبعا
ايضا اختير هذا الملعب الجميل اللي يقع
شمال الدوحه على مسافه 23 كيلو شمال
الدوحه ملعب جميل جدا ان شاء الله راح
نقول لكم تفاصيلها الملعب في نهايه النشره
همم نهايه برنامج صباح العربيه ملعب رائع
ملعب يعني
جميل في فعاليات طبعا للجمهور من بدايه
اصوله حتى الدخول في ايفنتات في اماكن
الجلوس وايضا اللي جايين بدري اماكن
للافطار في فعاليات منظمه للجنه المنظمه
لكاس العالم راح يستمتع فيها المشجع وراح
يستمت ايضا فيها المشاهد خلف شاشات
التلفزيون ملعب جميل جدا اعتقد انه راح
يكون من اعظم من الوزارات بعد كاس العالم
وهو هذه لذلك يعني اختير في نهايه اول
المباراه النهائيه لكاس العالم ان شاء
الله وفهد بنشير انه انت رح تكون معنا في
الساعه الثانيه من صباح العربيه ونذكر
بانه مباراه اليوم
معكم
من داخل الملعب باذن الله اوكي ومباراه
اليوم من ذكر كمان انه بين الارجنتين
والسعوديه ستكون الساعه 12 بتوقيت مكه
وبلانتظار ايضا الواحده بتوقيت قطر شكرا
لك من الدوحه مراسل صباح العربيه تحت
الشهريه